وامانه من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه بعد كل ما
استمعنا اليه هل يمكن معرفه على الاقل نوع
هذه الطائرات التي تقول روسيا ناستهدفت
وكان الهدف من ورائها اغتيال بوتين
الان لا يوجد معلومات لانه لم تقدم
معلومات واذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن الطائرات
في المسيره هناك المئات من انواع الطائرات
المسيره وهي تتدرج من من حجم صغير جدا
حتى تصل الى مسيرات تقطع مسافه عشره الاف
كيلو متر من مسيرات تحمل واحد كيلو جرام
متفجرات الى من سيارات تحمل صواريخ
وبالتالي ما لم يقدم معلومه دقيقه عن
الطائره الثالثه التي تم العثور عليها
نبقى نتحدث في اطار الفرضيات وبالتالي هذه
الطائرات تستخدم لاغراض تجاريه تستخدم
لايصال البريد والاستقداء الطلبات
الدليفري في بعض المناطق على سبيل المثال
الفيديو التي تم تداولها ونحن نشاهد هذه
النيران التي تلتهم هذه الطائره حينما
اقتربت من القبه قبه الكريملين هل يمكن
القول ان هذه الطائرات كانت محمله بذخائر
ام لا
يا سيدي الان يعني تابعنا الفيديو
اكثر من مره
الملاحق انه كانت الطائره يعني تم مشاهده
الطائره القادمه ومن ثم حصر الانفجار في
اللحظه الاولى او في المشاهد الاولى كنا
نتوقع انه اصاب الاداء لكن بعد ذلك تبين
ان ساريه العلم والعلم لم يتضرر وبالتالي
هذا يفتح باب التكهنات الكثيره جدا حول
مصدر الطائر لماذا لانه لو كانت الطائره
قادمه من اوكرانيا وسائل التعامل معها
مختلفه اولا الدفاع الجوي استخدام الليزر
استخدام عمليات التشويش واستخدام
المقاربات
الالكترونيك وهناك بنادق خاصه لكن هناك
اتهام اوكراني اخر يتهم سواء روسيا كمؤسسه
كدوله او اراديكاليان الراديكاليين الروس
وبالتالي اذا كان
الاتهام الاوكراني دقيقا فبالتالي اليه
التخلص من الطائره مختلفه هنا تكون من
خلال استخدام فيوزات
بدل ان يكون فيوز الصادم يعتمد على
الاصطدام بالهدف يمكن استخدام فنوع اخر
يسمى الفلوس التقاربي الذي تستطيع ان تحدد
متى ينفجر وعلى اي مسافه ينفجر وعلى اي
ارتفاع ينفجر وبالتالي ما ان الاتهامات
متبادله يعني لا نستطيع لكن الانفجار الذي
حصل لم يتم من خلال انا لم اشاهد صاروخ
اتجه باتجاهها قد يكون ان يكون قناص
الليزر